okay I'm going to talk very briefly
about hatred mail if you've never heard
of or heard an episode of hatred mail
here's something that will get you up to
speed on what we're talking about
because it's God's divine plan that
every child be born but an act of
patriotic duty to snuff that bastard if
he sets a foot near your stuff Patriot
Man written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom okay so sometimes patriot male
is more timely than other times
sometimes it's just insulting me but
sometimes it's insulting me with some
connection to what's going on in the
real world and that is what we have
today this is someone referring to
Donald Trump's platform in a very
particular way I'll just say that and
you can judge for yourselves
take a listen you guys are embarrassing
and totally clueless you're laughing in
the background makes you seem stupid why
would Trump discuss what he would do to
Isis are you crazy
national security wouldn't allow it no
time yeah someone actually believes this
as the reason why Trump won't really
tell us his plans for security
remember when Herman Cain pizza man
Herman Cain ran for president and any
time he was asked about anything I think
at the time the big one was his plan for
Afghanistan he would say I can't tell
you the plan now because then I'd be
giving it away and by the way also my
advisors that I haven't yet selected are
going to be the ones figuring it out in
the future that's also part of the
reason why I can't tell you the plan
right now at this point in the game it
is September 2 months before almost to
the day of the presidential election
right now if you're satisfied that
Donald Trump is not going into detail
about almost any proposal he has because
he wouldn't want to give it away there
is probably something as I like to say
the the wheel is turning but the hamster
has long died and I think that that's
what would apply to anyone who believes
that that idea at this point and if if
this is going to continue during the
National debates if Donald Trump is
going to show up and debate Hillary
Clinton and there is no doubt she is
going to be well prepared not only to
explain her plans for a variety of
issues but to very acutely call out
Donald Trump if and when he doesn't or
isn't able to or refuses to go into
detail about his plans Hillary Clinton
is going to come prepared and my hope is
and I know that there are so many low
information voters around who hear Trump
being vague and they say now it's okay
this is all an idea this isn't
necessarily exactly what Trump is going
to do I'm supporting Trump more because
I like the way he's discussing the
issues and he'll sort of figure it out
once he gets in hopefully some of those
low information voters will be swayed
and as always I'll remind you the coupon
code hate reott 40h atri o t four zero
can be used when signing up for
memberships at david pakman.com slash
membership if you use the coupon code
hey tree at 40 you can get a 40%
discount for life off of your david
pakman show membership